y hay un menor número de presas
asesinados que otros años 47 en total y
sigue siendo una cifra alta porque
supone que prácticamente cada semana un
periodista es asesinado en algún lugar
del mundo en ese sentido méxico está a
la par que afganistán donde 47
reporteros han sido asesinados es el
principal país teóricamente ahora en
guerra donde la actividad periodística
es extremadamente peligrosa este
descenso en el número de muertos lo
vemos porque los conflictos bélicos
están siendo menos mortíferos hablábamos
de los casos de siria irak y yemen y
también la pandemia
por otra parte pensamos que con los
consejos de reportado sin fronteras se
han logrado que los periodistas tomen
más precauciones pero también es cierto
que estamos experimentando
prácticamente en todo todo el mundo que
los grandes medios de comunicación
envían medios periodistas a cubrir
conflictos esto hace que muchas
instituciones bélicas muchas situaciones
peligrosas no están siendo cubiertos las
redacciones están cada vez más
precarizadas cada vez hay menos
reporteros internacional y la lectura y
la cobertura del mundo está siendo
precisamente por esta carencia